you saw his jet explode what if he was
abducted in that moment brought to the
Green Lantern Corps and it's across the
galaxy and then he is brought back so
maybe he's not completely the Steve that
she remembers he just jumped out of the
plane moved to Los Angeles and that's
why he has an age today Malina
[Music]
one of the major rock stars I'm Reena
masterís and Phillip is actually on a
father-son camping trip with Tommy today
another dad who is camping randomly and
this is rogue three guys yes today we're
talking about Wonder Woman 1984 the
trailer and how the hell Steve Trevor is
still alive right today we have Erik
Bosse is always great he's back again
Danny Park a ski hello who's here
sometimes and Leo Garcia hey it's me oh
great it's an all-boy panel ruled by a
lady queen so today on this episode
we're gonna talk about the Millennium
clock on the watchman right and how it's
gonna impact the finale of the show but
first we're talking about Wonder Woman
the 1984 trailer yes yes and guys how is
Steve Trevor alive how is he still alive
no idea yeah like how is he still alive
and is he still alive yes is it Steve
Trevor is it treats ever is it 1984-85
yes great all right so give me your best
reasons for why he's alive and how who
is he is he a ghost do you go I can go
take it away all right so um so the
there are several villains in this in
this movie and you have Kristen Wiig is
portraying cheetah but there's also
max Lord which if there ever was a old
comic-book villain named yeah it would
be max Lord and I I think part of the
reason that Steve could could show up in
this movie is that maybe there's some
deal that there's daddy's in this in
these worlds yeah perhaps could be a
deal that Wonder Woman has to make with
Max Lord and some of the deities to like
bring him back bring him back to life
but in as you see in the trailer he
looks sort of like lost and confused
perhaps in a very like bedazzled way
whether you're talking about the Peter
Cook and Dudley Moore version or the
Elizabeth Hurley and Brendan Fraser
version the better superior ya the
superior version uh that maybe when you
ask for something like that wish
fulfillment you don't get everything you
really want so maybe he's not completely
the Steep that she remembers but yeah
that that's sort of what I'm thinking it
could be how is he different what's he
missing like so his the left part of his
brain yeah that's why he doesn't
understand the fashions at the time yeah
so like we were talking before about
whether it's a Zubaz pants a Z cap
Ricci's he doesn't know how to Wang
Chung's does anybody really understand
the fashion of the eighties I don't
think so maybe so maybe he has it all
and surely everyone else that's missing
Hannibal let's see I'm gonna give you a
Rogi for starting things off in a way
that I understand
great great like a roadie just for
initiative will you beat out Eric so oh
yeah just by speed alone well my theory
I think one interesting thing about the
first Wonder Woman movie that I really
liked but people were kind of griping
that they wanted Steve Trevor's
character to be revealed to be Hal
Jordan to tie in the Green Lantern Corps
to the DC Universe he was not he was
just in the past but what if the reason
we are seeing Steve Trevor in Wonder
Woman 1984 maybe Steve Trevor is Hal
Jordan Green Lantern now yes and when he
died in the plane crash in the first one
wrong movie saw his jet explode what if
he was abducted in that moment brought
to the Green Lantern Corps
yeah and it's a
across the galaxy and then he is brought
back to be like her kind of friend but
he's still a man out of time he's still
left in and he's still the same guy but
it's kinda like fly to the Navigator
right you're on the other side of the
galaxy
you spent all this time due to the laws
of space-time in the way our bodies age
he's brought back to the year 1984 bunch
of knowledge is downloaded into his
brain yes and and Chris Pines a
verifiable superhero
if you ever asked me that guy had a
diamond on that Tim hi handsome fella
and he would be a perfect Green Lantern
I think like I agree with all the fans
like he's he's funny
he's a pilot yeah in the movie like he's
perfect for the role so this is the way
you could backdoor him too because we
know they have a Green Lantern Corps
project and development at Warner they
they want to make this into a thing why
not just use Chris Pine as your guy he's
gonna do it that's great and also like I
like doing it now because if he had also
been revealed to be a superhero in the
first Wonder Woman then that kind of
steals Wonder Woman yeah this whole
thing is like she finally gets a movie
like this is about her and then like we
throw in another superhero
dude like let her have her movie and but
I think now is like a great time to do
it cuz it's like great she also gets a
better golden suit so she's still happy
they can they can exist separately and
it's worth noting that like they told us
that Chris Pine was coming back in this
movie way early like the initial set
photos were of like in her new costume
Steven a Members Only jacket Members
Only with a fanny pack in the mall okay
like why aren't they hiding this this is
a huge twist so I think there's another
huge like band service you twist that
they got I love coming on the show and
me saying something stupid and then Eric
says something that could essentially
like yeah that is probably what's going
to happen legitimate but you have to
allow yourself to be stupid and say
things like time is a flat circle and
baby Yoda equals Yoda and that kylo Ren
is reincarnated them all sometimes you
get these yeah most of Eric's world um
but sometimes he's real smart and he
gets to roads - wow that's a lot of road
whoa doling these roadies out close
enough to reach I'm just gonna go for it
I got I got a lot of theories on this
one he's a cocaine nightmare too
he just jumped out of the plane moved to
Los Angeles and that's why he has an age
today Phillip Molina he has never done
cocaine sorry I cut you out three he's a
hologram but I won't go into that no
going to hologram leave so the song in
the trailer is um but that song was
ripped off that was from another that
was taken from another song called Jerry
and the Holograms and so that's like
obviously Diana is able to interact with
things that are intangible from like
flinging her lasso on the lightning it's
a it's a bad theory but it is a theory
it's a very rare and I expect to get for
roadies because I'm gonna give you a
fourth and final theory that's actually
decent Eric's with the abduction but in
my theory it is not abduction by an
alien race but an abduction by one of
the gods from Diana's Pantheon ah I
think that like a lot of the gods if not
all the gods were killed by Ares the
original one but I think maybe Zeus
survived or at least there's a large
Greek pantheon so there could be some
like lesser God involved like extended
cousins that Ares didn't think to check
off yeah exactly like pan or something
and pans like you know Diana's really
gonna need Steve for this one so let me
just pull them out and pop them back
when we need him in the 1980s of love
that's Aphrodite know it also makes
sense for why he seems confused about
everything
time yeah 1917 and they love God I loved
I loved that one part of the trailer
where she's like all of this is art and
he's like yeah oh cool there's some
trash can engineer who's like you know
what duct tape it onto a wall in Miami
great guys tell me how many row geese
you have I have one because I'm in the
two Rogge club over here nice yeah to
row guys over here - all right great
let's take a small break to thank our
sponsors hey guys Eric here just another
reminder if you want early access to all
of our Star Wars content of which we
were doing so much breakdowns of
episodes of the Mandalorian on Disney
plots an in-depth re-watch series of the
classic Star Wars films original trilogy
and prequels and of course all the news
you need to know about the rise of
Skywalker you're really gonna want to
subscribe to our podcast feed WikiLeaks
I know we're kind of proud of the name
that way you'll be the first to be
alerted when new Star Wars information
comes out from us and you'll be able to
consume this content while you're doing
other stuff like driving working out
cooking or realistically I know what
you're doing with your time practicing
your lightsaber skills again subscribe
to WikiLeaks wherever you get your
podcasts we've all been really into the
Watchmen yeah oh yeah - Bo spoiler
warning if you're not coming up on the
show of course because we are gonna talk
about predictions and if any of them
happen to be true then we will have
ruined your life
the last two episodes have explained
several of the big mysteries the show
has had dangling over the season but one
big one remains yeah
what is the millennium clock and what is
Lady trues plan to use it and I expect
answers based on science
I expect answers based on Holograms
music I expect one of the answers to be
sung oh I'm not singing mine so I'll get
mine out of the way first although I
will really get one
them's the rule uh the Millennium clock
is actually the will nem clock oh and
it's for will Reeves but it what a
justice Big Willy style yeah yeah big
hooded style and uh no I think I think
what the millennium clock is and this
would be the most sort of no easy answer
but I'm going there anyway is that it is
a time machine of some kind right I
think it links into a lot of the stuff
from the the books themselves you know
everything is concerned with watches and
time the way that dr. Manhattan
experienced this time but I think is
annoying it is annoying so do you think
that somebody's gonna go back to the
events of so much of this of the series
has been based in like generational
trauma yeah and I think there is a way
what a lady true wants to go back to say
her origins or her mother's pains and
like write those whether it's based in
Tulsa because they want to go back and
write the the wrongs of Tulsa the black
Wall Street Massacre or even if it's
just to go back to you know undo what
they did in 85 86 maybe 6 1984 yeah yeah
go back to 94 watch Wonder Woman boy and
then you know undo you of 8 did with the
squid monster and in Times Square I do
think that that though obvious seems
like yeah if they if they undo the the
squid monster though then who's gonna
stop the nuclear apocalypse maybe they
let it happen maybe like we're in some
alternate timeline where it's like this
is even worse to get super rogue there
is an offhand comment in one of the one
of the episodes where they say the
Russians are developing an intrinsic
field generator what if the Russians had
a dr. Manhattan and one of my favorite
science fiction movies is Colossus the
Forbin project where America and Russia
both have these supercomputers it's a
control of all the nuclear arsenals and
they agree with each other they
essentially start talking to each other
and say hey we're not gonna start a
nuclear war because we know what's best
for you guys but now you guys have to do
it we we say awesome well like
benevolent Skynet sort of benevolent
Skynet but I think no one wants to be
ruled by machines Evelyn Skynet I live
in that reality man if machines just
want to take over everything right now I
would save me so much stress that was
great that's a very good theory really
did you where'd you do oh it's hanging
over my hand bring it back I won't slap
it out of your hand
okay and I will give you one point two
five rooms
Wow recorder because I don't want anyone
to be embarrassed to say the theories
that seem obvious because sometimes they
need to be said yeah yeah just put it
out there and then we and then we get to
different places well sometimes it's
obvious but not for obviously hey hang
on a second if you want an obvious
theory you want an obvious theory lady
true told us what the millenium clock
does yeah it tells time for singing but
I took it back for that joke fine
whatever
no like she was directly asked what does
it do and she says it tells time and on
I'm gonna want that back because
honestly I think that's what it does you
were talking about the symbolism that
clocks had in the initial series and I
think that there are two big things that
clocks are symbolic okay symbolic of one
would be the impending apocalypse the
nearness to midnight
right exactly tick-tock tick-tock you
gonna die the other one would be
determinism this idea that we live in a
universe run by a watchmaker god you
know a twister clock maker everything is
precisely refined such that if you have
if you have a complete understanding of
the workings of a watch you can know
where that watch is going to be a
hundred a thousand years into the future
a millennium perhaps selenium
a will.i.am and so I think that lady
true is where she is today in part
because of information from the future
that she got from dr. Manhattan through
will yeah she she knows exactly when
that whatever it is is going to hit that
person's that couples farmhouse and
that's why she has to buy it right
before it heads in she says you've got
three minutes to decide she knows
precisely when that's gonna strike she
knows what she has needed to do to get
to this position I think that she knew
when to buy adrian veidt's company
because she knew that he had been
transported to europa and i think that
she understands the value of seeing the
future and so she's creating the
millenium clock to tell time and not
just tell time but see forward through
time so what to what end whoa
to what end and that's that is the
question and i i'm the betterment of him
cuz originally like if you can compare
the two big things like whether it's a
squid in the millennium closet or the
two things will go off in the book in
the series one was a bad thing that was
probably save humanity yeah what is this
thing seems benign yeah what does it do
she does seem to want to save humanity
she says she's got a plan to save
humanity it starts here in Tulsa I don't
know I do have an idea of like what I
think the final shot would be like if
that is her goal and what I really want
it to be is will Reeves asking her so
was it worth it all in the end yeah and
her saying nothing ever ends
I think it's baby Yoda I'm gonna trade I
took away your quarter Roby but I'm
gonna give you a full row all right so
there you go okay so I put a lot of
thought into this I think watch them in
the series not like you I put very
little thought I think it's all about
eggs and every time I say everything at
new rocks there should be egg based Phil
Broyles his eyes because we hunt Easter
eggs everything baby Oh des isn't an egg
shell when we find him
I think Watchmen has had this running
sub
concept the sub theme of fertility of
bloodlines of yet genetics yeah eugenics
so like in the opening pilot you see
like she's making omelets she's making
like an egg based dish will Reeves eat
eggs out of the out of the boiling pot
dr. Manhattan with her husband she slaps
the eggs out of his hand drinks beer
with an egg lady true presents the egg
to them and she gives them the
opportunity for fertility in order to
take their farm and and it's an egg they
you have eggs that they're that's what
they sell yeah they're farmers so what
is Lady Troost whole master plan what is
her plan to save humanity I think the
the clock that millennium clock is
connected to biological clocks and
women's biological clocks I think her
master plan is to make every white woman
on the planet and every white man on the
planet infertile in order to truly
correct historical wrongs in her mind
it's a radical notion it's just in the
the type of mindset that Adrienne bate
would have like let's do something
radical and then truly give people of
color a chance to have children and to
retake the definitely put her directly
in opposition to the seventh Cavalry
directly yeah because their whole plan
is to like reclaim white dominance you
know in their eyes so how do you like
maybe you don't kill all them but you
kill their chances of having a future
not a little too hard to be a white man
would be would be proven right in that
case but like you can imagine that's her
plan and like it ties in with her like
given the this white couple a chance to
have a white baby like very much it's
alright this will be the last white baby
oh wow that's great and that's also
that's great I say we wipe out now all
in favor say yeah we could call it honky
gettin your they're allowed to say that
we're not your Nazi you're not allowed
to say yeah but I like that because the
whole this series of Watchmen is based
on a historical wrong that is completely
left out of our history books I
didn't learn about it until college
maybe I think which is the black wall
street massacre in Tulsa and this
actually overlaps with real-life
atrocities where there was mass
sterilization of Native American women
in the United States and there was in
the 70s and 8 to say it went into the
eighties to of Mexican American women
who would go to the doctor for either
pregnancy or just a regular like some
other procedure and they would be
sterilized without their consent and it
happened like it was a definite thing
that happened so I wouldn't be surprised
if they're like they started off this
series in like this stuff is real it has
been done and we're gonna address it
head-on and I would not be surprised if
they're like you know what this has been
done to Native American women and
specifically Mexican American women like
let's turn the tables list yeah it's
something that like Hitler's Third Reich
wanted to do and you could argue there
is a form of like systemic racism in
this country when black women who are
pregnant go to the doctor that just
looks like four times as likely to lose
that as well and it's like maybe doctors
aren't actively thinking about it but
they are less likely to care about the
future of black children in this country
and there are white children so help
conscious bias yeah and this is
definitely something that Damon Lindelof
we're not imbuing this this is fertility
has been core to his work and lost like
there was that whole subplot when you're
on the island suddenly are yeah you can
people who are infertile can have kids
on the island and in the leftovers like
fort it like what's her character was
pregnant and she loses the baby the baby
gets raptured and that was like a whole
huge thing that happened in the series
so clearly I think that is score to
Damon Lindelof interests i he's been
pretty overt about it yeah everything he
said that like nothing is he's not
trying to hide anything so like whatever
yeah whatever's on the show is going to
happen yep eggs are everywhere do so you
had your like like this is how the show
ends or the series end yeah yeah season
what do you guys did you guys say they
were like this up this I mean
it's really dark but like montages of
white women in fertility clinics
screaming and crying cut to like 30
years in the future and there's like no
it's like children of men for white
people a final shot
maybe a little cliched but the end is
the beginning is the end we get we go
back to Tulsa 1921 her time machine has
transported dr. Manhattan in current
form to Tulsa and he stops the the
massacre oh and that alters that alters
history and some a couple way or or he
doesn't stop the massacre but he does
save will Reeves yeah oh he's the one
who saves him instead of or he's his dad
or whatever like the the car the car
that will Reeves was in got like this is
already the time to loot where he gets
sent yeah it's a loop
dr. Manhattan is the one who pulls give
me a recap of the score so far because
it's about to be time for a road
question oh I have two and a quarter yep
2.25 I'm in the three Rogge Club over
here and me to cheers my friend
Cheers there's always time for me to
catch up right guys these are real
questions you don't know what they are
at all and neither do I actually and
I'll be minute to tell you the rules for
when I'm hosting whoever really has the
funniest answer have to be like clever
funny just to make me laugh and I love
stuff that's real dumb can just make
funny faces yeah obviously or like if
you fall down like that my bar is very
low a great bro crush number one a photo
went viral
I will photo went viral of a guy's
tattoo a baby oh drinking a white quoi
okay I'll save it for my viral of a
guy's tattoo of baby o2 drinking a white
cloud which is insane how could the
tattoo have been even more
20:19 I want to see the tattoo of the
person who gave baby Oh to the white
clog getting arrested because that baby
is underage he's 50 but not in Yoda you
I would say if the person giving baby
out of the white cloth I don't know I'm
sticking with that say yeah that's a no
is Kanye and his silver pupil
we're all just looking for the man
behind the curtain right yeah I think to
make it more 2019 you'd have in addition
to baby owed on the tattoo you to have
Greta gromberg looking at baby Oh done
going okay boomer great number two Mad
Max fury road director George Miller
defended superhero films as cinema what
superhero franchise would we love to see
George Miller direct Squirrel Girl great
next that was hard to say I'd like to
see George Miller take over the
post-apocalyptic like Batman V Superman
nightmare future that was gonna happen
to do with Mad Max it's great and I want
to see that it's funny none of your
making me laugh oh yeah Archie on the
big screen
finally and it'll just be multi ops and
in the post-apocalyptic world don't give
any of us just give yourself one myself
no it's okay I'll give you one because I
asked right after I said none of you're
making me laugh I felt real bad about it
so that's a guilt drug right there okay
never quit number question three go back
okay it came out this week that part of
the reason Sony and Marvel were able to
strike a deal over super fighting over
Superman whoa that's breaking news on
you rock stars no one's gonna say a
common
about that in the comments at all ever
no no one's going to say just restart it
nope over spider-man was that Tom
Holland made a drunken phone call to my
gir I don't know that's funny
give me your best drunk Tom Holland
impression okay
now this now this I'm ready Bob I just I
just want to play spider-man so bad
before this all I had was Billy Elliot
and I uh I just it's the best thing I've
ever gonna do dance ballet Bali just
dancing the ball a drunk he sounds to me
what's Tom Horne's favorite alcoholic
drink it's him holding baby Oh drinking
away guys we kept me your points what's
the score I have three in a corner three
party 545 I'm in the four and a quarter
club what is Tom halls favorite
alcoholic drink the better answer wins
red stripe Eric's wishes that Eric gets
to sing his baby Yoda will abide okay
baby cries you were singing me dead but
it's all coming
bando first two parts of the verse done
yeah that's great guys that's it for
this episode of rogue theory thanks for
watching new rock stars thanks for
watching rogue theory guys Leo Garcia
we're can you where can we find you on
the Internet in B wired.com I have a
podcast they're called millions of
screens we talk about TV we actually are
going to be interviewing listen and see
what he was thinking while he was making
the finale yeah exactly
Danny prick ASCII where can we find you
you can find me on instagram or twitter
at danny perk as that's me for all the
social media stuff Eric you can find me
at ei vas on Twitter and Instagram and
we'll be having some fun videos coming
out this weekend we're finishing up our
Star Wars re-watch series attack of the
clones went out on Sunday and then
Revenge of the Sith coming out on
Tuesday oh yeah ex week it's all Star
Wars stuff baby oh yeah lines marina
masters and I'm also Philip Malina I'm
currently on a camping trip with my son
right now we're roasting marshmallows Oh
dr. Molina yeah doctor really did I'm
also Eric Voss because I have this great
jacket
[Music]